it's like not it doesn't work well with
me welcome back we've all been on bad
First Dates oh my gosh even the bad ones
though are such good comedy to talk
about with your friends that at least
that makes it worth it um but it does
make us want to run for the hills
sometimes and lose Faith you know it can
be hard but our resident expert Sarah
Jane ho um is here to teach us how to
navigate some tricky dating
situations Sarah Jane as literally an
etiquette expert an our resident
etiquette expert you've changed my life
with things that you've done and said so
we've never talked about dating I cannot
wait to get into this with you like how
often do people ask you as an etiquette
expert about dating oh all the time I
mean everything from online dating um
profile pictures online profiles on
dating apps to First Dates to you know
even people who in relationships there
still a lot of etiquette I mean it runs
the gamut from first date to like
mother-in-law really oh I hear that oh
jeez I am so sorry I'm late hi are you
drew hi I'm Ross on your date sorry I'm
late I just had a busy day he was meant
to be here on time but I sorry just I
hate being late sorry sorry about that
um anyway this is going to be fun great
to meet you
hi okay what's awful is I feel like I'm
actually you I'm always the one who's
late but Sarah Jane like what does one
do in that scenario I'm her date get it
okay great
okay yeah you wouldn't be the first gay
man a
on so it's important to remember not to
be judgmental because accidents happened
maybe the train actually broke down um
or there was a family emergency that
Ross had to take care of no I was just
in the bathroom for a really long time
we definitely do not want to over how's
the date going so far like most of mine
so so the key thing is to just not say
anything and let them explain themselves
if they don't explain themselves then
just write them off what would you
really do if your date really walked in
like super late and didn't have a good
excuse how would you really react um I
would probably say I'm usually the late
one I can't believe it wasn't me this
time that's exactly what you would say
is that good or bad that is a great
etiquette response Drew you did it you
did
it are you so proud of yourself because
usually I'm like the a I'm Sarah Jane's
example of what not to do and I'm happy
to be that because a lot of us you know
are trying to figure things out okay
what about when you're trying to get to
know someone and like they can't say off
their phone like Ross is doing right now
I'm sorry
what so this is interesting the number
one number one pet peeve that people
have on first dates is the other person
playing on their phone too much oh yeah
I was on a date once and someone was on
their phone and I looked at their phone
and you knew what they were looking at
grinder they were on they were on an app
looking at other
people what do you say about that well
in that case I'd be like oh who are you
looking at on grinder I want to check
him out too oh wow that's the cutest
response I've ever heard yeah oh you're
like oh he's cute you should go out with
him
bye later or if you're getting to look
at other people I'll join you and look
for a better option as well that can we
say that uh maybe not in those
on okay what is a good exit strategy for
a date because I feel like I've needed
them quite a few times like this this
day in particular how's it going so far
terrible Ro day yeah I mean you're
really Hamming it up and yet this is
clearly what people deal with like my
yeah when was Lost first dat um it was
with um this very interesting man who is
a very he's he's someone who's changed
the world very like high-powered it was
very weird for me because I I don't
really date anyone who's ever like
wealthy or powerful and so it was a
Trippy date I was he had so many
interesting ideas the intellectual
conversation was so stimulating and then
we didn't live in the same area and then
I just said eventually you know I'm not
really good at dating over text um it's
been a couple months of us texting and I
just have to be honest I'm more of an
in-person person so if you'd like to get
together in person I'm all in and if not
I totally understand that's good yeah
and then he said oh my god let's make it
happen and
then the night before he said I just
remembered that my best friend's 40th
birthday weekend is happening
and I can't see you and I
thought your best friend who's turning
40 and has a birthday weekend is not
something you remembered last minute so
I just said thanks for letting me know
because that's better than being ghosted
and you know I got my answer which was
it's definitely not on yeah well I I
have a question so this date went
terrible right so we're not a match Drew
but let's say that this date went great
okay and it's like a hubba hubba kind of
moment your place or mine kind of moment
and I'm really doing it for you drew
right you can't keep your hands off me
Sarah in that
scenario when when what date what is the
like is it first date second date third
date where you you know what I
mean what's the number the fifth date
what not that I'm against one I stands
listen if you want to have sex on the
first date there are really no rules
around that as long as it's consensual
but if you're looking for something
serious wait till date five because if
you have sex too soon it'll Cloud your
judgment you want to really get to know
this person before sex is in the picture
before it's lust and passion so that way
you can decide with a clear mind is this
the right person for you and then date
five um okay what is it that's the one
thing that you hear that people are
looking for like the most in life what
do they want on that first date what
what's the goal you hear the
most I think it depends on where that
person is and everybody goes on dates
you know for different reasons some are
really just looking for one night stand
some are looking for a serious
relationship I think the most important
thing is to go with an open mind and not
like I think date one should be about
just getting to know somebody and the
vibe don't I wouldn't go too hard and
heavy on date one right so the biggest
mistake I see people make is saying oh
first date should be at really fancy
dinner God no it should be every first
date of mine it's the worst a coffee a a
happy hour something where you can
control the time and if it doesn't go
well you say well it was so great having
coffee with you okay yeah my line to get
out of any situation is well this was
fun right it works every time well in
all honesty this was fun and Sarah Jane
ho I love you so much like you always
illuminate things from me in a way I
wasn't thinking about it before the best
thank you I love you we'll be right back
this is a great
day